in this lesson we're going to talk about
how to use the quadratic formula so what
is a quadratic formula why would we use
it that's what we're going to talk about
in this lesson so sometimes when you're
solving an equation it might not be easy
for you to factor it so what you can do
to find out the value of x is use the
quadratic formula you learned about this
in your algebra 1 class but basically
what you're doing is you're just taking
the opposite of b so the opposite
quantity here so if it's negative this
will be positive positive this will be
negative and you're just substituting in
the a b and c values and you're
simplifying this expression you could
get two
real answers one real answer zero real
answers but two imaginary answers
depending on whether this b squared
minus four ac comes out to you know a
positive value zero or a negative value
but let's go ahead and get into an
example here so see if you can pause the
video try this one on your own and then
we'll go through it together so here it
gives us this equation 2x squared minus
5x minus 12 equals 0. it's a quadratic
equation because it's to the second
degree and we're just trying to find out
the value of x so how do we do this
problem well
of course the act is multiple choice and
you could take the answers a b c d e and
put them in and see which one gives you
zero that's definitely one way to do it
the other way to do it is you could of
course factor it but it might be
difficult to factor so another
possibility is to use this quadratic
formula and that's what we're going to
do right here so a is 2
b is negative 5 okay you want to make
sure you capture that sign and c is
negative 12. okay so if we substitute
those values into our quadratic formula
we get the opposite of b which is the
opposite of negative 5 which is positive
5 plus or minus b squared now negative 5
squared is negative 5 times negative 5
that's 25
minus 4 times a which is 2 times c which
is negative 12
all divided by 2 times a
and we've got it so now we just have to
simplify
5 plus or minus now let's see
we've got 4 times 2 is 8
okay times negative 12 is negative 96 so
we have 25 minus
negative 96 which is actually like
adding 96 so what does that come out to
121 right so this is the square root of
121 over 4 the square root of 121 is 11
so we have 5 plus or minus 11 all over
4. now we can simplify it's like two
problems in one 5 plus 11 is 16
divided by 4 is 4.
5 minus 11 is negative 6 divided by 4
which is negative 3 halves so it could
be 4
or negative 3 halves those are the two
solutions or in math means both like
union so these are your two solutions
again you could figure this out by
putting these values in for x and see
which ones give you zero
but if you wanted to use a quadratic
formula this is how you would do it or
again you could factor it so definitely
something important to know i'll see you
in the next lesson